the helicopters hovering in slowly and
approaching the crane from the south
all right now he's coming in on his
second pass this might be the past where
they attempt to make contact with a
stranded crane operator rescues are a
spectacle there's almost nothing that
captures our attention more than
disaster striking and finding out that
someone of the plane credibly has
survived and needs help has lifted the
firemen and the victim off the crane at
this time so he's out of danger ever
seen a rescue like that 19 years of
flying we owe a great deal of credit to
those guys down there that were able to
pull that rescue off it can seem
voyeuristic sitting on our couches or in
our offices and watching events that are
far away that we are removed from but in
a way these are the most essential
stories stories of great peril of hope
and of bravery a woman is rescued after
being trapped 17 days maybe they touch
on something that's universal hope that
when we're lost someone will look for us
that strangers would risk their lives to
save us
and maybe it's a reminder of just how
fragile we are after being buried for
seven and a half days a seven-year-old
kid named Kiki it's what relief looks
like the relief of being reunited but
being grateful about being alive that's
what the best parts of humanity look
like